we're taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
let's go to our next caller from the 501
area code call or what is your name and
where are you calling from hey Dave this
anthony from Morrilton Arkansas great
what's on your mind um I was going to
ask you if um let's see oh shoot shot ah
forget all right well we lost that call
we're taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
let's go next to our caller from the 832
area code caller what is your name and
where you're calling from this is
chicken bone a lot calling out of
houston texas all right what's on your
mind I click question with this I would
have been listening I'm trying on the
road but uh this new voice thing by by
Trump what could be the possible benefit
what's the spin that they're trying to
say is the need that we have for this I
not having any idea I've not been here
just a lot of years far I've not looked
into this a lot so far I was I saw a
couple things about it earlier Pat but
I've not heard about this what was this
the voice voice it's an acronym yeah
what does it stand for again do you
remember I I ullin some immigrants or
victims of immigrants or you know a MIDI
year I can't even quite remember it just
was so stupid when I heard it I couldn't
believe it got it came out in a speech
like that I think the idea is just to
try to create some seemingly more formal
infrastructure or setting to talk about
individual crimes committed by
undocumented immigrant which can then be
used to justify whatever policy it is
Trump wants to justify whether it's the
wall whether it's banning people from
particular countries from immigrating to
the United States it's a PR pretext more
than anything and usually when
Republicans talk about immigrants
they're careful enough to you know
preface that word by saying undocumented
or illegal he didn't do that or in
who have committed crimes violent time
right yeah and he didn't do that you
could hear an audible gasp from the
audience after he said that yeah it's PR
and you know what the thing is it's
going to work with some people some
people will hear that and they're going
to eat it right up like it's being
spoon-fed to them and they'll say see
we've got to ban everybody which of
course would have included them and
their ancestors at some point if we had
drawn a line in the sand so yeah it's
pee its propaganda it's probably going
to be effective for some people though
but blatantly self-serving yeah
absolutely thank you so much for the
call really appreciate it will say well
what else develops wazzup yeah
appreciate it alright we'll take a break
join us on reddit david pakman.com slash
our EDD IT will be back with more after
this